sophia wir reden über männer ja wir
reden über männer komplett in einem
thema jetzt geht es los geht los ich bin
das ist mein lieblingsthema also
lieblings in anführungsstrichen als sehr
bizarr also die
die gleichstellungsbeauftragte vom
auswärtigen amt hat einen knigge
herausgebracht für verhaltensweisen also
die männer sich eigentlich verhalten
sollen wenn man sich mal anschauen da
ist zum beispiel punkt 2 das ist mein
lieblings punkt des ganzen das heißt
lasst emotionen zu also männer sollen
praktisch emotionen zulassen weil sie ja
per se eigentlich überhaupt gar keine
emotion haben und angestaubt wochen
keine inflation zulassen sondern das
sind ja nur wir frauen männer überhaupt
nicht oder ich wann hast du das letzte
mal regelmäßig eben gerade zum beispiel
schon aber
emotionen würden einfach mit dazu
das kommt ja so ein bisschen auch dann
in mein thema mit was man noch politiker
korrekt machen muss und es wird momentan
ja wirklich übertrieben es ist ja ein
sehr harter hat wenn wir gerade über das
reden was in afghanistan ist wir haben
corona wir wirklich ganz viele themen
aber mittlerweile haben wir auch
wirklich ein großteil müssen uns mit so
was irgendwie auseinandersetzen was man
jetzt als mann frau richtig in den
auswärtigen dass du sagen kannst für
viele ist ja eigentlich das ist ja ein
politiker korrekt dass sie eigentlich
gar nicht richtig geht sondern es ist
wenn er dinge ab verlangt die ja
eigentlich
ja eigentlich normal sind also ist wenn
er dinge ab verlangt wie sexualisierte
gewalt wenn sie die beobachten bitte
greifen sie ein bitte was steht da steht
auch noch eher helfen sie ihrer frau im
haushalt denn wenn sie es nicht tun wird
sie werden sie am burn out bekommen das
heißt wenn die frau
bekommt amira hat die burnout weil du
nicht im heutigen zeit muss ich hier
sein also wenn man das sagt selbst ja
auch immer dann auch noch abgewaschen es
ist darauf sagt es ist ja es geht ja
noch mal ist es ja es ist es auch auf
gewisse art und weise wird ja auch ein
sehr
steinzeitliches bild auch gezeigt von
mann und frau und viele sachen sollte
normal sein aber ja es gut aber dass das
auswärtige amt sogar also ich meine das
auswärtige amt also die hätten jetzt
momentan echt noch drei andere themen
die sie machen aber darum sich jetzt
ganz wichtig sind ich finde es
wahnsinnig bevormundend und ich finde es
werden dinge abverlangt die eigentlich
selbstverständlich sind und man verkauft
die leute eigentlich so für dumm und das
finde ich was ich so wahnsinnig recht
wenn das werden einfach bitte bitte
bitte machen sie das bitte schauen sie
zu bitte helfen sie ihrer dame im
haushalt bitte benutzen sie generell
sprache ich meine es ist mir immer oder
den männern auch selbst überlassen ob
sie bitte gerne richtige sprache
benutzen möchten oder nicht und da steht
doch warum wir das machen sollen sie
sollen also sprach verwenden um frauen
und nicht binäre personen sichtbar zu
machen also
und ich wie oft hast du denn schon nicht
binäre personen sichtbar gemacht ja ist
es das ist ein thema wir wollen jeder
randgruppe ist recht machen und das kann
man leider nicht machen aber
ich weiß noch nicht mal genau was nicht
binäre personen sind also ich da das war
computer erste stunde dass es mit nullen
und einsen damit binärcodes aber nicht
wenn ihre personen weiß ich ehrlich
gesagt nicht aber jede randgruppe hat
jetzt auch sein recht auf
wahrgenommen zu werden aber zum channel
haben also vier jahren hast du selbst
auch nicht nicht wurde heute als gästen
eingeladen als ich habe heute mal wieder
eine linke nachricht bekommen wo ich in
einem podcast eingeladen wurde liebe
gestern habe ich mir nicht mal mehr die
anfragen durch leser haben uns zurück
geschrieben ich komme nicht als gäste
das ist nichts für mich ich bin gerne
gas punkt ich finde dann an die
feministisch ich finde schottern ist
anti feministische warum darf ich nicht
gast sein aber da wird so sein wie du
oder ich finde es wird zu- und ich würde
dann ich finde für mich wird das anti
feministische in dem moment wenn ich als
frau sage ich möchte nicht ändern ich
benutze keine kinder richtige sprache
und dann werde ich von frauen eigentlich
ausgegrenzt und sagen was sie besitzen
keine gerner gerechter sprache das ist
aber nicht mehr zeitgemäß und dann werde
ich von den von der aus den eigenen
reihen von den damen eigentlich
ausgegrenzt bei ich halt nicht bereit
bin zu gern lern und da wird es dann
irgendwie komisch aber viel
interessanter begriff endlich zeitgemäß
ich überlege schon manchmal also
insbesondere in gesprächen mit meiner
tochter 16 für dieses selbstverständlich
zu gendern also für die es
selbstverständlich dass man kein fleisch
isst und es ist selbstverständlich dass
man im flugzeug fliegt und so weiter
also diese sie quasi die volle packung
schief gelaufen
ich weiß heute gehört es kommt aber es
regt mich zu dem gedanken an ob wir
nicht vielleicht schon die alten sind ob
jetzt nicht gerade eine große
veränderung passiert an der wir nicht
mehr teilnehmen können aber für die
nächste generation ist das schon völlig
klar also in einer talkshow in 20 jahren
wenn es dann noch talkshows gibt ist es
dann wahrscheinlich völlig normal wenn
man in zehn jahren nicht gehst in
einlädt dann kommt keiner mehr also dass
ich alles umdreht und ich habe sogar ein
beispiel es vielleicht so wie man vor 30
jahren im flugzeug ganz normal geraucht
hat und wenn man es heute ist völlig
klar dass man es nicht mehr vielleicht
sind wir uns zu einer veränderung welt
beim und sind nur zu langsam oder zu
essen oder zu alt oder zur tradition des
toten mit einer krawatte aber es ist ja
ein bisschen anders ich glaube er und
der punkt ist glaube ich ganz ganz
richtig denn sophia gerade auch gemacht
hat zu sagen da werden eigentlich alte
klischees ja bestätigt nämlich gast der
mann nicht ab wischt dass der mann also
nur an männer denkt eigentlich dass der
mann nice blog ist sowie olli pocher und
überhaupt nicht
aber stimmt
auch nicht
ich glaube eher dass die
gleichstellungsbeauftragten ja museum in
der sendung nie was vorne also ihr
glaubt dass in deutschland wie die
männer stoppt die männer
der punkt jetzt mal teil widersprüchlich
ist das ja zum beispiel drinsteht
männer geht in elternzeit es geht also
männer die einen beruf haben und eltern
vater sind ein drittel der männer
möchten schon in elternzeit ich habe es
ja schon sorgen dass genau warum schnell
dicht dahinter
unseren anteil zu ihr glaube dass wir
schon in elternzeit geht hier um die
beschäftigungstherapie es geht auch um
der legitimierung ich muss als
gleichstellungsbeauftragte ja auch immer
wieder sagen warum bin ich eigentlich
wichtig das ist gleiche übrigens beim
thema lohnlücke männer und frauen das
wird ja auch immer wieder kritisiert von
den gleichstellungsbeauftragten ja da
wird aber das managergehalt oder eines
top manager mit mit dem gehalt verglich
in einer beispielsweise friseure die nur
20 stunden die woche arbeitet das ist da
ein riesen unterschied gibt ist ja klar
der wird ganz bewusst immer wieder
dargestellt ist aber falsch wenn ich
äpfel und birnen vergleichen dann muss
ich sagen dass apple und dessen birnen
ja das wird aber bewusst
zusammengeworfen glaube schon es geht um
den grund legitimierung ich muss immer
wieder sagen wie schlimm etwas ist auch
wenn es falsch ist wenn die lücke gar
nicht so groß ist oder wenn männer
mittlerweile wie selbstverständlich auch
elternzeit nehmen oder auch abwaschen
staubsaugen emotionen zeigen ich muss es
aber immer wieder sein dass das nicht so
ist sonst verliere ich meine legitimität
männer wenn du mit mann aus bist und das
sagt dann abends das ist als sein
größtes sein größtes ist jetzt auch ein
nicht binäre personen zu denken was
passiert dann ich sage jetzt das ganz
schlimme ist und ich werde dafür von
allen zuschauern gehasst dass es noch
schlimmer als wenn ich darauf antworten
würde ich weiß gar nicht ob ich von
meinem partner wollen würde dass er in
elternzeit geht und da möchte ich auch
was anderes eingehen das private ist
privat das heißt mein verlobter ich
werde irgendwann die entscheidung
treffen müssen wer von uns kümmert sich
das ist aber eine super private
entscheidung ich frage mich immer was
der staat eigentlich vor will arbeit
bestimmen was in meinem privatleben
stattfindet und ich denke mir wenn man
als man zum beispiel ein drittel der
männer würden gerne teilzeit arbeiten
wir müssen jedoch den arsch in der hose
amtshaus zu sagen so kannst du bitte
mehr arbeiten ich will zu hause bleiben
ich habe ist noch eine private
entscheidung vielleicht will ich aber
und fünf jahren dass mein verlobter zu
hause bleibt und dann werde ich zum
sagen so du bleibst jetzt zu hause da
muss ich aber auch die cholera anbringen
dass ich so ekelhaft wenn er an diesen
ganzen dingen ist ja eigentlich dass man
also man möchte ja eigentlich den lesern
da hier sie suggerieren dass man als
hausfrau als frau die sich dafür
entscheidet ihre kinder haut zu hause
großzuziehen keinem beruf nachzugehen
sondern hausfrau also die damen die
hausfrau sein wollen dass das an sich
verschlechtert ist dass man irgendwo
abgestellt wird als hausfrau und was sie
möchte auf ihre kinder achten ihr findet
es das wird immer so abgestimmt wie so
oft da hat es nicht geschafft weil der
mann will ja unbedingt arbeiten gehen es
gibt aber bestimmt ganz viele frauen die
das einfach auch so möchten und ich
finde das darf auch respektiert werden
und das darf man nicht immer so
abstempeln wie als als hätte man keine
ambitionen das nächste ganz wichtiger
punkt glaube ich und das nächste ist
dann ja das dann dass es dann wieder
heißt egal der mann oder die frau in
teilzeit geht weil man sagt da möchte
sich jemand stärker auch um seine kinder
kümmern wie jetzt die
gleichstellungsbeauftragte sagen wenn
man dann in teilzeit geht dann heißt die
teilzeitquote ist so hoch sind viel zu
viele leute in teilzeit das passt ja
auch nicht zusammen also entweder wollen
wir dass ich meiner und frauen stärker
um kinder kümmert also brauchen wir auch
mehr teilzeit dann kann man aber
umgekehrt nicht wieder sagen augen die
teilzeitquote das ist alles wie so
wollen wir nicht das geht zu lasten von
männer oder frauen das passt alles nicht
zusammen also wir lernen der zettel das
ding ist altmodischer als die an die sie
wendet er das ist wahrscheinlich die
innere logik
[Musik]